Your brain is sabotaging you all the time!
WHO CAN WE EVEN TRUST?
Anthony here for DNews and your brain is built
around survival in a harsh, unforgiving environment.
Unfortunately, those survival loops can cause
us some harm in our safer, smarter modern
world.
Here are 3 things your gray matter is a little
too black and white about.
Have you ever kept watching a show, week after
week, even though you don't like it?
Or finished eating a meal at a restaurant
even though you were full because you already
paid and you didn't want the money to go to
waste?
That's the Sunk Cost Fallacy That food was
already made for you.
It's as wasted as it's gonna get the moment
it hits the table.
You don't like that show, watching more hours
of it doesn't make those other hours less
wasted.
On a larger scale, it can cause bad investments
and keep people in the wrong relationships.
Whyyyyy, brain?
Because in order to survive, early humans
had to prioritize loss.
Losing a home, food, a mate could mean death.
Not losing is more important to us than gaining.
Sunk cost takes place in the lateral front
and parietal cortices, which are involved
in risk-taking and aversion.
When we're losing, our brain only thinks in
terms of saving the situation, not what's
best for us.
On the flipside is something called optimism
bias.
No matter what the odds of something bad happening
are, we tend to believe it's less likely to
happen to us personally.
Divorce rates in the US are 40%, but newlyweds
rate their likelihood of divorce at 0%- even
if they're divorce lawyers.
Smokers think cancer is less likely to happen
to them, people think unprotected sex can
result in pregnancy and infection- but probably
not to them if they do it this once.
I won't get alzheimer's, I won't get mugged.
What the what, brain?
Specifically, what the what, inferior frontal
gyrus?
THAT'S IRRESPONSIBLE.
But optimism's linked to knowledge of our
future- if we're smart enough to picture a
happy life, we're smart enough to picture
death.
And constantly thinking about death and failure
doesn't sound like the behavior of a growing,
thriving species- so people who are hopeful
survived in our early history and helped us
reach all the great achievements we have.
We also know that stress has negative physical
effects on the body- so optimists make for
healthier, longer living humans.
Finally, let's talk about one that I'm always
trying to avoid- but I'm never sure if I'm
doing a good enough job.
Confirmation bias.
We hang out with friends who have similar
interests.
We read news from sites that agree with us.
We have a sense of beliefs that defines who
we are- and we tend to only seek out or information
that aligns with those beliefs.
Other stuff just doesn't hold our interests.
A 2009 Ohio State University study says we'll
spend 36% more time reading an essay that
aligns with our opinions.
It's more pattern recognition- teaming up
with the like-minded meant a stress-free survival
in early society.
But it's bad when it's applied to news, media,
research, or politics.
Because if you just keep confirming your own
thoughts instead of seeking out full truth
of something, you actually wind up less intelligent.
So how do you avoid this stuff?
Well, short of transcranial magnetic stimulation
to your brain, the best thing you can do is
be aware of it and try to question yourself.
Have you ever caught yourself doing one of
these things?
Let us know down below and subscribe for more
DNews.